what is the value currently of prime
it's about 8 to 10 billion we're in a
group chat six Partners was Logan one of
those yes we were a week away from
launching something happened in the
group chat JJ got offended JJ emailed
the lawyers hey I don't want to do this
I'm out and deleted himself from the
group chat wow yeah called Logan and I
said hey I need to talk to you Logan was
aing Superstar about it very
understanding he was like look it's it's
cuz we've all done so much work for this
so the way he reacted was so cool I then
went back to JJ and I said listen you
can't just say no I'm not doing this as
a man this isn't something that is right
just do me one favor we have a call say
your peace they'll say their peace and
if at the end of that call you say to me
Ms don't want to do it I'll never bring
it up again he said to me you're right
catch the full podcast this Sunday with
The Man Behind ksi's music the president
of misfitz boxing a co-founder of drink
Prime it's Mom's Taylor on the true
Jordie